so this is benzene it's an organic
compound so it's a ring of six carbons
with hydrogens coming off each carbon
benzene is a very interesting molecule
its structure has six carbon atoms each
with one hydrogen atom attached to it
it's used as a solvent benzene actually
quite carcinogenic we found out now that
actually causes cancer it's pretty toxic
so so we have to treat it with the
utmost respect the stretch mystified
chemists how could you have six carbons
and six hydrogen's all in one molecule
when Benjamin discovers people didn't
actually know what the structure it was
they knew it had six carbons and six
hydrogens they didn't actually know what
sort of form it took and basically it
was down to somebody called kaki lay who
proposed the structure of benzene and
apparently the structure of benzene came
from a dream he had where he dreamt of a
snake eating its own tail he dreamt
there's a snake was biting its own tail
and he developed the idea that benzene
was a ring apparently so he says
afterwards but the actual structure
wasn't worked out until the 1930s when
crystallography showed that it really
was a flat molecule and the chemist
named Kathryn Lonsdale who was the first
woman ever to be made a fellow of the
Royal Society the bridge UK Academy of
Sciences she worked out the structure of
benzene the structure of benzene is a
hexagon of carbons a hydrogen comes off
of each carbon what we have is a double
bond double bond double bond so we have
a double bond single bond double bond
single bond double bond single bond so
the way chemists often draw benzene is a
suit is a hexagon with a ring in the
middle to show that the electrons are
delocalized as we call it so over each
carbon the delocalized over each carbon
and benzene is an aromatic compound we
call aromatic compounds compounds that
have these sorts of structures Michael
Faraday made a sample of benzene early
in the 19th century and in about 1980 a
bottle was found labeled Faraday's
benzene and the British company BP who
wonderful and analytical labs analyzed
benzene faraday's benzene and it came
out to be purer than modern benzene when
you buy really high purity benzene so
everybody was a bit suspicious was this
Rayleigh Faraday's benzene but it had 37
trace impurities tiny impurities that
and which they also saw and then another
bottle of Faraday's benzene was found in
a different lab in London and it was
analyzed and it had exactly the same
impurities it was found out that the
reason that Faraday's benzene was so
pure is that benzene freezes at quite a
high temperature goes solid at about 6
degrees centigrade and Faraday used
crystallization rather than the modern
way of purifying it which is
distillation which is much better on a
large scale but doesn't give you quite
such a high purity product and bending
has an unusually high melting point so
it becomes solids at five point five
degrees so hopefully when I put it some
ice and see if we can get it to go solid
benzene has been found
moderately recently in the last 40 years
or so to be toxic it's not an acute
poison it doesn't make you drop dead
immediately but it can promote certain
cancers particularly leukemia so when I
was at school people use benzene quite
freely but nowadays we wouldn't let
school children or even students use it
except them special precautions I found
here this is my school LED book which I
did experiments about 46 47 years ago
it's got some quite nice pictures in it
and here there's an experiment which I
did preparation of nitrobenzene
this is reacting benzene with sulfuric
acid and nitric acid and I used 50
milliliters of benzene that's really
quite a large amount nearly two ounces
of benzene and nowadays this would not
be allowed at all at school
so we're in our few can cover so what we
have here is just mice put a lot bit of
water in it hopefully get a nice nice
contact between the test tube and the
ice this is just a normal test tube what
I'm going to try and do is put some of
the benzene in the test tube I'm going
to have to leave it for a little while
enough to wait and see benzene itself is
not very spectacular looking at all it's
a colorless compound so that's what it
actually looks like
but benzene's prayer benzene rings are
present in lots and lots of compounds so
benzene itself is toxic but lots and
lots of compounds with benzene rings in
them aren't so benzene as I showed you
was in things like aspirin tin as a
benzene ring in paracetamol you'll find
benzene rings in lots of compounds and
so benzene Zin TNT so it's
trinitrotoluene which is an explosive so
you'll find benzene in a lot of places
it's in an amino acid benzene is the
simplest example of what is called
aromatic compounds I suppose because
some of the materials that are made from
benzene have a nice smell Nitro benzene
which I made at school smells a bit like
almonds and a huge number of different
chemicals are based on aromatic rings
like benzene and one of them for example
is terephthalic acid which is what's
used in making plastic bottles benzene
is also used in lead-free gasoline
lead-free petrol because benzene burns
differently from straight chains of
carbon and hydrogen atoms and so by
having benzene in lead-free petrol you
can avoid the need to have LED and allow
car engines still to function properly
because otherwise when you press the
accelerator the car starts juddering and
doesn't go uphill properly so what we
have here now is the benzene in the
bottom of the test tube I'm just going
to put it in the ice and hopefully we
can get it to freeze
hope this ice is cool enough wait you
see benzene is potentially dangerous but
since it is burnt in the car engines the
passengers should not really come in
contact with it very much but this is
why for example you should not try and
siphon gasoline out of a car by sucking
on the end of a tube to get the siphon
going because the benzene in it is
poisonous it is not as poisonous as the
lead was before but it's still not
something that you should be taking into
your mouth okay so we're checking up on
our benzene we've put we put a little
bit of benzene we squeeze a little bit
of benzene from this bottle into the
bottom of this test tube and we've put
it in some system is obviously hopefully
the item of water surrounding this is
about zero degrees and the melting point
of benzene is about five and a half
degrees centigrade so it's actually
actually should be solid in our ice so
if we have a little look at our benzene
okay actually it's on its way it's not
quite I know actually new is frozen
benzene is also used somewhat strangely
for making very high purity alcohol if
you make alcohol by fermenting glucose
in water you get a mixture of alcohol
and water and you can then start
distilling it however when you distill
it you can only get rid of most of the
water and you're still left with about
two and a half percent of water in the
alcohol and however much you distill it
you can never get rid of that last bit
however if you add a little benzene to
the mixture of water and alcohol then
the benzene allows you to distill off
almost pure alcohol but now you have
just a trace of benzene in it and
benzene as I said is quite poisonous so
this is why you should never try and
drink alcohol that's used in the lab
because it will contain traces of
benzene and could be very bad for you so
our bending is is frozen so hopefully if
I
this upside down fingers crossed it's
frozen benzene which freezes at five and
a half degrees C